Mark Hamill made it abundantly clear from
the start that he didn't agree with the direction
writer-director Rian Johnson wanted to take
Luke Skywalker in Star Wars: The Last Jedi.
"When I read VII I told Rian I fundamentally
disagree with virtually everything you've
decided about my character."
And now that the movie is out, we can see
what he means.
In an interview posted by YouTube user JarJar
Abrams, Hamill opened up about his problems
with Johnson's take on Skywalker and the character's
defeated mentality at the beginning of the
film.
"I said to Rian, 'Jedis don't give up.'
I mean, even if [Luke] had a problem, he would
maybe take a year to try and regroup.
But if he made a mistake, he would try and
right that wrong.
So, right there, we had a fundamental difference.
But it's not my story anymore.
It's somebody else's story, and Rian needed
me to be a certain way to make the ending
effective."
Hamill said Skywalker is so different in The
Last Jedi that he essentially considered Luke
to be a completely different character than
the one George Lucas created.
When asked about one line that Luke says,
presumably that "the Jedi must end," Hamill
said,
"That's the crux of my problem.
Luke would never say that.
I'm sorry.
Well, in this version, see I'm talking about
the George Lucas Star Wars.
This is the next generation of Star Wars,
so I almost had to think of Luke as another
character.
Maybe he's Jake Skywalker.
He's not my Luke Skywalker.
But I had to do what Rian wanted me to do
because it serves the story well.
But, listen, I still haven't accepted it completely."
Of course this interview is from before the
release of The Last Jedi, and Hamill ended
it on a pragmatic and positive note.
"It's only a movie.
I hope people like it.
I hope they don't get upset.
I came to believe that Rian is the exact man
that they needed for this job."
Asking fans not to get upset about The Last
Jedi?
Now that would be the greatest Jedi mind trick
Luke ever pulled.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!